you know you know inspired album too
that [ __ ] Jizzle
who YG oh he did we had a show the other
night in Orange County do you guys it's
the album coming out the same day so you
guys that's a good day for La Hip-Hop
come on man he was like
we ran into each other at the show
and we was backstage just chopping it up
you know what I'm saying and we just was
chopping it up just about what we need
to be doing as far as me and him like
nobody else doing it me and you need to
be doing this and you're like I'm
driving on 30 I said [ __ ] I'm gonna drop
on the 30 or two he said bro we got to
like you know what I'm saying and that
was yeah I mean you YG Tai we were just
talking a bit like you guys really are
like an era of this La [ __ ] like you
guys really kept La alive for the goats
a very long time I think I think it's
it's at an era where it's like and let
me take that back
um
YG and Todd accomplished more than me so
I'm not gonna even put that goat thing
on myself I'm real like honest and real
YG mustard and Ty have accomplished a
lot more than Joe Moses so I'm not the
goat you know what I'm saying I'm I'm
just a staple I'm a factor you're a
pillar definitely so that's I'm I'm so
hard on myself bro like you know I mean
um
for all the good reasons though you know
I'm saying Ice Cube is the goat Dr Dre
is the goat Snoop Dogg is the ghost Too
Short E40 the more ghosts DJ Quick those
are goats we just and I could say Ty and
and YG and mustard have accomplished way
more than Joe Moses so I can I can call
them the goats too I'm not afraid to get
my friends their props of course I'm the
next one to have that ghost status